Ja genau, also wie ihr schon gesagt habt, mit dem Licht und diesen ganzen wunderschönen Gadgets, die einem das Leben leichter machen, finde ich ja eine ganz tolle Sache. Ist auch richtig, nur manchmal macht mir das echt auch Angst. Also ich habe diese Lampen gekauft von Philips und die funktionieren super. Die funktionieren mir mit Geo-Tracking, das heißt, wenn ich auf einer gewissen Strecke zu meinem Haus bin, gehen die an oder aus, je nachdem was ich eingestellt habe. Was mir aber bei Geo-Tracking dann echt Angst macht, ist, dass mein Smartphone mir anzeigt, wie viele Minuten ich jetzt von dem Standpunkt nach Hause brauche, bei normalen Verkehr. Das hast du bei Google angesprochen hattest. Ja, das ist mir letztens immer aufgefallen, ich fahre eine gewisse Strecke, relativ oft zur Arbeit oder zu der Freundin oder so. Und ich stelle mein Auto dann ab. Und wenn ich dann wieder an dem Punkt bin, wo mein Auto abgestellt wurde, sagt mir mein iPhone, so und so vier Minuten brauchst du jetzt, obwohl du nicht weißt, dass ich mit dem Auto fahren möchte, nach Hause. Und das ist, seitdem ich dieses Geo-Checking aktiviert habe, bei meinen Lampen bzw. bei meiner Heizung, macht es das. Und das finde ich echt ziemlich bedenklich.
Also quasi das iPhone beobachtet dich einfach nur und hat halt festgestellt, wenn du an diesem Ort bist, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass du jetzt dort hin willst und deswegen sagt sie das.
Oder wie? Genau, also ich wusste ja, dass Apple beliebte Orte, heißt das bei Apple glaube ich, Daten sammelt. Das kann man ausstellen, das ist auch kein Geheimnis. Aber das ist dann so, ich finde offensiv, die eine Push-Up-Benachrichtigung aufs Handy sendet, finde ich, also woher weiß es, dass ich nur, weil ich jetzt am Auto bin, wieder mit dem Auto fahren möchte.
Google macht sowas ähnliches auch, das sagt dir dann, wo du dein Auto geparkt hast. Also es erkennt, dass du aufgehört hast, dich mit einer Geschwindigkeit zu bewegen. Und wenn du dann zurückkommst vom Einkaufen, sagt das dir, wo dein Auto steht. Und manchmal funktioniert es nicht richtig, dann sagt es einem auch, wo das Flugzeug steht, wenn man gelandet ist. Das ist dann ganz lustig. Aber die machen das auch. Das wird dann auch nicht lokal gespeichert, sondern irgendwo auf einem Server.
Und das zum Beispiel ist, von dem Beispiel, was ich vorhin erzählt habe, ist es das Gegenteil. Ich bin so ein Typ, ich fahre manchmal Auto und dann relativ lange Strecken wie der öffentliche Nahverkehrsmittel. Und mein Wohngebiet ist relativ dicht bewohnt. Das heißt, es gibt so drei, vier Standardparkplätze. Aber wenn ich das Auto da nicht abgestellt habe, dann weiß ich nicht, wo es ist. Dann muss ich halt wirklich suchen. Und da habe ich auch immer gehört, es gibt so Apps, die halt die messen. Also du stellst halt an, dass die dich überwachen und dann messen die einfach irgendwie die Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt, die erkennen, wann du Auto fährst und wann du nicht mehr Auto fährst. Und machen dann genau dieses Ding. Können dir sagen, wo du dein Auto zum letzten Mal geparkt hast. Und das wäre eigentlich so super praktisch, weil es wirklich einmal im Monat vorkommt, als ich mein verdammtes Auto suche. Aber andererseits ist es mir auch zu gruselig. Also ich möchte nicht, dass eine App mich überwacht und sozusagen und online irgendwo abspeichert, wie mein komplettes Bewegungsprofil ist. Ich habe mich jetzt aber vorher dagegen entschieden. Du Kenny hast dich ja sozusagen dafür entschieden, das zu machen, aber findest es trotzdem komisch. Was ist denn jetzt das komische Gefühl bei dir?
Das Ding ist, das hat es ja nicht.
Also ich habe mir diese Produkte für die Lampe geholt und habe dann entschieden, bzw. auch für die Heizung und habe jetzt im Winter entschieden, bzw. wenn ich jetzt lange nicht zu Hause bin, dass ich dann halt meine Geräte übers Internet steuern kann. So Heizung oder Licht oder... Ich habe auch überlegt, mir auch mal so eine schöne Webcam zu organisieren, aber eigentlich nur Spielerei. Aber seitdem ich mir halt entschieden habe, dass mein Licht angehen soll, wenn ich 50 Meter vor meiner Haustür bin, sozusagen, seitdem ich dieses Geo-Tracking aktiviert habe, ist mein Handy, also der Anbieter Apple, schickt mir diese Push-Up-Nachricht. Seitdem macht das Handy das ja. Und das ist, ich weiß nicht, auch heute die Meldung, jeder guckt 80 Mal auf seine Apple Watch. Also ich gucke definitiv weniger auf meine Apple Watch, aber welche Daten veranlassen jetzt Apple, so was rauszuhauen?
Ich glaube, die Apple Watch hat so ein Ding, wenn du den Arm nach oben drehst, also das Display nach oben geht, dass erkennt man diese Bewegung.
Ja, aber die befragen ja nicht die Leute, sondern sie sammeln die Daten der Uhr.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und das heißt ja, dass mein Handy, Apple, greift auf eine fremde App zu und hat dadurch ja irgendwie eine Kompetenz.
Ist es nicht umgedreht, ist es nicht so, dass die App beim Handy abfragt, wo bist du gerade?
Nein, also bei diesem Philips-Tuning musste ich mich online anmelden. Auf der Hinterseite musste ich das Geo-Tracking aktivieren, damit die mein Haus sozusagen orten können. Weil ich habe ja auch diesen Zwischenrouter hier im Haus, damit es funktioniert. Und ich weiß nicht auf welches Datenmaterial sie zugreifen, aber es müsste ja auch mit Samsung funktionieren.
Nochmal was?
Also ich weiß nicht auf welches Datenmaterial Philips zugreift, und dann ob die eine eigene Map haben oder von TomTom oder was weiß ich.
Eine Karte brauchen sie ja nicht. Die können einfach über die Schnittstellen vom Handy, also die Mobilbetriebssysteme haben ja alle Schnittstellen, wo man dann anfragen kann als App, wo bin ich gerade, wo bewege ich mich. Und ich denke mal, dass in dem Zuge auch Apple natürlich jetzt dadurch, dass eine Applikation regelmäßig deine Location pollt, natürlich auch Apple das Profil wesentlich dichter hat. Also die Handys machen es auch so, dass sie den Aufenthaltsort nur dann wirklich fein granular ermitteln, wenn eine Applikation gerade den auch haben möchte und ansonsten eben nur so grob tracken. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass in dem Zuge Apple da eben jetzt auch mehr Daten bekommt, weil das eben im Betriebssystem aktiv ist. Aber da bin ich jetzt auch kein App-Profi.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, als ich das erste Mal gesehen habe, hat es mich schon echt erstaunt, was heutzutage so alles an Daten.
Was ich spannend finde, ist, du hättest ja jederzeit die Möglichkeit, zu sagen, ich mache es nicht mehr, sondern ich steuere meine Lampen nur von Hand und mache die Ordnungskontakt. Das machst du aber nicht, also so sehr stört sich dann doch nicht, oder? Also es ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl, aber es ist nur ein bisschen unangenehm.
Das ist halt, man macht nicht seine Gedanken. Aber andererseits denkt man sich auch, okay, wenn jemand wirklich meine Daten haben wollen würde, in irgendeiner Art und Weise und so interessant bin ich halt einfach nicht. Ich bin ein kleines Licht in Berlin, sag ich mal. Dann würde der auch durch andere Wege auf meine Daten zugreifen. Ich mache es derjenigen Personen oder dem Unternehmen halt einfacher. Okay, gut, aber und liebe Quemlichkeit ist es dann natürlich. Also abends im Bett zu liegen und nicht noch mal aufzustehen zum Lichtschalter zu gehen, sondern einfach auf der App auf ausdrücken.
Nee, das meine ich nicht. Du könntest ja diese App benutzen, aber deine Lampen nur noch per App manuell steuern, also manuell per App sozusagen und nicht mehr dieses Ordnungsding machen. Das ginge ja auch.
Das ginge auch, ja. Aber das ist dann trotzdem die Bequemlichkeit, eine warme Heizung zu haben oder Licht schon anzuhaben, wenn man ins Haus kommt.
Also du willst nicht nur von ferne Steuern können, du willst auch nicht mehr dran denken müssen.
Richtig, weil ich auch einen Kopf voll mit anderen Dingen habe und so ein kleines Helferchen machen lassen natürlich.
Tja, und so verkauft er seine Seele an dem Teufel.
Entschuldigung, kurze dramatische Untermalung der Geschehnisse.
Das ist vollkommen richtig. Ich habe meine Seele schon damals verkauft, als ich mir mein erstes iPhone bild habe. Mittlerweile habe ich glaube ich fast alles von Apple. Also von daher, ich bin sowieso nicht rettbar.
Alles klar.
Hast du schon irgendwie neue Anschaffungen noch geplant? Was kommt als nächstes?
Na, also die Apple Watch war jetzt das letzte.
Ich meine so Smart Home Internet of Things mäßig, nicht ein Apple Produktkategorie vervollständigen.
Na ja, die smarte Waschmaschine ist dann das nächste bestimmt, wenn die dann auf den Markt kommt.
Aber da frage ich mich auch mal, was soll denn daran smart sein? Es hilft mir nicht, dass ich die von ferne ansteuern kann.
Na doch, du kannst sie anmachen, damit sie fertig ist, wenn du zu Hause bist.
Also bei meiner Waschmaschine zu Hause kann ich sagen, hier, mach dich voll und dann starte bitte so und so viel Zeit.
Ja, aber vielleicht kann sie sich erst einschalten, wenn der Strompreis günstig ist nachts, damit die Nachbarn maximal genervt werden.
Was ich aber wirklich interessant finde, und das ist jetzt kein Scherz, das ist der Kühlschrank, der mit Internetzugriff, dem du erlaubst, Essen nachzubestellen oder Produkte, die halt da sind.
Aber der wird uns ja versprochen, seit es die Idee davon gibt.
Ja, und auch seit sechs Jahren den Flughafen schon versprochen.
Warte, der Kühlschrank of Things ist der Flughafen?
Meiner Meinung nach krankt das Ganze sowieso an der großen Wahnsinnigkeit der Kühlschrankhersteller, die glauben, dass alles, was man irgendwie isst, in einem Kühlschrank gelagert wird. Und man vergisst dabei, dass zu einem Essen noch ganz viel andere Sachen gehören.
Naja, aber Gegenargumentation, sozusagen im Kühlschrank hast du das, was schnell schlecht wird. Das heißt, da sind die Kaufzeiten geringer, während du halt Nudeln kannst auch vier Kilo in deinem Kabuff legen.
Ja, aber der Lieferant kann dir vier Kilo Nudeln vor die Tür legen. Ein Steak, was den ganzen Tag vor der Tür auf dich wartet, ist vielleicht nicht mehr so geil. Also frische Sachen liefern ist nicht so einfach.
Warte, das Steak kommt nicht durch die Internetleitung direkt in den Kühlschrank rein? Und viel Spaß noch mit deiner Ordnung. Ich finde es wirklich spannend. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass noch mehr Leute von euch anrufen und auch erzählen, was sie für Erfahrungen gemacht haben mit dem Internet of Things oder mit Dingen, wo sie mal gesagt haben, okay, meine Daten darfst du haben. Ich will es mal bequem haben und wie die Erfahrungen für euch sind. Ich finde es wirklich spannend. So, und dann müssen wir noch über Puppen reden.
Ja, was die wenigsten Leute wissen, Hacker haben ein großes Herz für Puppen, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn in dieser Puppe einfach mal ein Computer verbaut ist. Und so auch hier passiert, nämlich Mattel hat jetzt eine Hello Barbie rausgebracht. Was unterscheidet die zu einer Hello Barbie von einer normalen Barbie?
Du wirst es mir sicherlich gleich verraten, Danimo.
In der Tat, die Hello Barbie, mit der kann man nämlich vordergründig als jemand, der mit ihr spielen will, reden. Die hat so einen Button und da kann man dann draufdrücken und dann kann man ihr was erzählen und die antwortet sogar. Also da ist halt so ein ähnlicher Algorithmus drin verbaut oder so eine ähnliche Funktionität drin verbaut, wie man sie auch bei Siri, Cortana, Google Now, wie sie alle heißen, ist. Jetzt könnte man sagen, naja gut, das ist das selbe Szenario, das wir eben beschrieben haben. Nämlich man überlässt Fremden die Sprachaufzeichnung, in dem Fall nicht nur von Erwachsenen, sondern sogar von Kindern. Aber es ist natürlich noch schlimmer, natürlich ist es noch schlimmer, in dem Fall ist es nämlich noch schlimmer, weil was passiert, wenn so ein Device jemand in die Hände kriegt, der gerne die Weißes aufmacht, er stellt fest, dass das ganz schnell ganz doll kaputt geht. In dem Fall war es eben so, dass sobald diese Barbie, die verbindet sich also übers WLAN mit dem Internet, um dann mit den Servern reden zu können, die dann die Sprache interpretieren und auch die Antwort liefern. Es scheint also so zu sein, dass, wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt, dass man sehr einfach quasi die Eigentümerschaft über diesen Chip, der da verbaut ist, übernehmen kann und damit dann nicht nur Zugriff auf dieses Mikrofon im Kinderzimmer hat, was irgendwie schon schlimm genug ist, sondern dieses Gerät kann irgendwie auch noch die letzten Nachrichten, die das Kind mit seiner Puppe besprochen hat, abspeichern oder tut es sogar und auch das kann man dann im Nachhinein abrufen.
Das ist sogar ein Dienst für die Eltern. Also die Eltern können auf eine Webseite gehen, sich anhören, was das Kind mit der Puppe gesprochen hat und das auch noch mit anderen Eltern im Internet teilen.
Das ist die dritte Eskalationsstufe, weil ich das in der Tat noch schlimmer finde, wollte ich das jetzt auch noch erzählen. Das ist offensichtlich so im Helikoptereltern, Zeitalter Mode geworden, dass man auch wissen will, was die Kleinen so mit ihrer Puppe reden. Und das ist dann unter Umständen so süß, dass man das auch noch teilen möchte.
Oh, mich ist gerade ein bisschen schlecht geworden. Und das verkaufen die so offiziell als hier, das ist total toll. Und diese Puppe, ist das dann so auf Knopfdruck nimmt die auf oder nimmt die eigentlich immer auf?
Naja, sie nimmt, ich sag mal im Lieferumfang, sie nimmt im Lieferumfang nur auf Knopfdruck auf. Aber dieser Knopf ist einfach auch nur ein Software-Schalter. Und nichts, was jetzt jemanden, der auf diesem Gerät drauf ist, wirklich daran hindert, da einfach auch das Mikrofon auf Dauerlisten zu stellen. Und das einzige, woran es vielleicht auffällt, wie üblich ist, dass der Barbie schneller die Puste ausgeht im Sinne von Strom.
Wow, gab es eigentlich sozusagen einen Aufschrei, außer jetzt bei Leute wie euch, sage ich mal?
Es ging halt durch die Presse. Ich habe es hier inländisch tatsächlich nur in der IT-Presse verfolgt. Es scheint da nicht groß darüber hinausgeschwappt zu sein, wobei ich mir auch nicht sicher bin, ob es die Puppe schon für den deutschen Markt gibt, wo es definitiv große Wellen geschlagen hat, ist im englischsprachigen Raum. Aber ob das wirklich die breite Bevölkerung erreicht hat, kann ich nicht einschätzen.
So, das ist also auch Internet of Things. Gibt es noch mehr so Horrorgeschichten?
Ja, zum Smart Home gab es ja, die Telekom betreibt sowas ja auch. Denen ist halt neulich mal ihr zentraler Server ausgefallen. Und da war dann der Fall, dass die Leute, obwohl es anders versprochen wurde, ihre Lampen nicht mehr schalten konnten.
Also die Lampen haben dann nicht mehr funktioniert, also komplett nicht mehr.
Genau, also die Ansage war wohl, dass es halt auch ohne Internetanbindung geht, solange du dich zu Hause befindest. Dem war dann aber wohl zumindest beim Teil der Kunden dann doch nicht so. Und letztendlich, man muss halt auch immer daran denken, solange an so einer fernsteuerbaren Steckdose irgendwie deine Stehlampe hängt, ist das alles nicht so schlimm. Aber Menschen stecken halt in Steckdosen so ziemlich alles ein, was da rumsteht. Das kann halt auch mal die Herz-Lungen-Maschine der Oma sein oder dein Kühlschrank. Wenn du deinen Tiefkühlschrank, weil du warum auch immer auf die Idee gekommen bist, daran anschließt, dann hat die Cloud auf einmal Regen. Dein IoT-Device sagt, ich gehe mal in einen unklaren State und dann geht dein Kühlschrank aus, du kommst nach Hause, die Oma liegt in der Ecke und der Kühlschrank ist abgetaut.
Das sind jetzt so zwei Dinge, die möchte ich ungern miteinander vergleichen. Aber man sieht den Punkt, wo aufzunehmen wird. Es gibt doch außerdem auch immer mal wieder so Sicherheitsgeschichten. Das habe ich mich eh vorhin gefragt, als er einen der ersten Anrufer erzählt hat, irgendwie die Daten würden irgendwie unsicher übermittelt, die da alle anfallen. Das ist ja auch ganz spannend. Und es gab sich neulich irgendwie mit einem der Hersteller auch so ein Skandal? Der jetzt irgendwie gerade SIGB oder wie die hießen?
Ja, grundsätzlich hast du natürlich immer das Problem, diese Geräte müssen sich irgendwie miteinander unterhalten. Und das haben wir eingehends gesagt, man kann sowas halbwegs sicher implementieren oder auch nicht. In dem Fall dieser SIGB Geschichte geht es darum, also das sind auch so diese Philips Hue Lampen zum Beispiel, die sprechen ein, wie nennt sich's, Profil von SIGB. Ein Profil ist da immer so ein Subset von Featuren und das ist das...
Und SIGB ist ein Protokoll erst mal.
SIGB ist sowas wie WLAN und davon gibt es verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen.
Also es ist eine Art und Weise, wie diese Geräte übereinander sprechen.
Genau, es ist ein drahtloses Funkprotokoll oder eine Sammlung von Protokollen. Eine Geschmacksrichtung davon ist dieses SIGB Light Link, was der Name schon andeutet für Lichtsteuerung gedacht ist. Und das Problem, was du ja hast, also wenn du jetzt irgendwie mit deinem neuen Handy nach Hause kommst, dann gibst du deinen WLAN-Code da ein, dann ist das in deinem WLAN. Ein ähnliches Phänomen, du kommst mit deiner neuen Glühbirne nach Hause und die muss irgendwie mit deinem SIG B-Netz reden. Aber da du ja nicht willst, dass da jeder mitspielen kann, gibst du halt ein Passwort oder einen Schlüssel oder was auch immer. Aber wie gibst du dir diese Glühbirne ein? Die hat ja keine Tasten.
Stimmt.
Das heißt, du hast dieses Problem des initialen Provisionierens dieses Gerätes. Und in dem Fall war es so, ganz stumpf gesagt, dass es halt so einen Key gab, den die alle hatten, den darf halt keiner wissen, außer den Herstellern. Und damit können sie sich dann initial mit deiner Basisstation unterhalten, werden ins Netz integriert und alles ist gut. Solange niemand außer den Herstellern diese Schlüssel kennt und diese Schlüssel in die Lampen reintut.
Verstehe ich aber nicht. Wie kann das gehen?
Naja, stell dir einfach vor, es gibt ein geheimes Kotwort für die Gruppe, in der du sein möchtest. Du und deine zehn Freunde kennen das. Niemand versteht dich, solange er das nicht kennt. Und solange ist das auch total gut. Und wenn du neun in die Gruppe aufnehmen willst, dann sagst du ihm das geheime Kotwort und alles ist gut. Und wenn jetzt dein Freund eine Lampe ist, dann sagst du ihm das nicht, sondern das hat der Hersteller ihm dann schon gesagt. Und solange das kein anderer kennt, ist alles gut.
Ich verstehe es immer noch nicht. Wie kann denn eine Lampe wissen, wie das Passwort zu meinem WLAN ist?
In dem Fall ist es nicht dein WLAN, sondern dein SIGBI-PAN. Aber das Passwort kommt vom Hersteller. Das ist schon in deinem Router drin. Also das Ganze ist etwas komplexer. Man kann das jetzt nicht so in fünf Minuten erklären.
Warum nicht? Es gibt Geräte, die diesen Standard sprechen.
Die sagen es anders. Alle Lampen und alle Geräte haben vom Hersteller ein und denselben Key da reingebrannt. Und damit verschlüsseln sie die Kommunikation. Und solange niemand diesen Schlüssel kennt, der böse oft ist, der deine Lampen steuert.
Aber das heißt, das ist gar nicht... Das Problem kann durchaus sein, mein Nachbar hat solche Geräte, ich habe solche Geräte, dann kann es zu Verwirrung kommen.
Na, normalerweise nicht, wenn der Nachbar nicht böse ist, weil diese Lampen, da gibt es halt noch so Dinge, wie du musst es irgendwie an die Basisstation dranhalten. Aber wenn du diesen Schlüssel kennst, kannst du halt auch sagen, hallo, ich bin die Basisstation, sprich mit mir, auch wenn du gar nicht meine Lampe bist.
Also das Problem ist, normal, das Sicherheitskonzept lebt davon, dass in diesen Lampen alle derselbe Schlüssel verbaut ist quasi.
Also wenn ich diese Lampe kaufe, dann tue ich diese sozusagen dicht an eine Basis-Sendestation und durch die physikalische Nähe weißt du dann, okay, das ist das WLAN, mit dem ich reden soll.
Das ist das SIGBI, mit dem ich rede. Genau, das sogenannte PAN.
Da geht es wirklich über die physikalische Nähe. Und dann ist der Datenverkehr, der über die Luft stattfindet, verschlüsselt zwischen diesen beiden Punkten.
Genau, und für die initialen Kommunikationen haben sie von Werkau schon einen Schlüssel dabei. Darüber unterhalten sie sich. Und wenn sie das getan haben, rechnen sie sich einen neuen aus. Danach ist es alles nur noch hebso wild. Aber für diese initialen Kommunikationen haben sie alle den gleichen dabei.
Das heißt, wenn denen jemand redet, kann er jedem gerät, dass er per Funk erreichen kann, sagen, ich bin eine Basisstation.
Und statt zu erreichen, wenn überall dieser Schlüssel drinsteckt, dann kann man sich das Raten sparen und kann einfach versuchen, da dran zu kommen.
Aber du musst doch schon in der Nähe sein.
Man nimmt das Gerät auseinander und liest es aus und hat dann diesen Diffus.
Nein, das meine ich nicht. Mein Nachbar hat SIGBI-Geräte.
Dein Nachbar muss schon in deiner physikalischen Nähe sein.
Ja, genau, aber das reicht. Wenn die sozusagen in Funk-Reichweite sind und ich diesen Schlüssel kenne, weil ich den aus so einem Gerät rausgebastelt habe, dann kann ich mit dem reden und alles machen. Nein?
Ja.
Ja, gut.
So, und dieser Schlüssel ist rausgekommen. Das heißt, den weiß jetzt jeder.
Im Prinzip.
Ja, er ging über Twitter.
Stimmt, ich hab auch einen Tweet gesehen. Da kam so eine komische Zeit. Das heißt also, wenn ich diese Geräte zu Hause habe, dieses SIGBI, wie heißt das, Light-Lite-Protokoll sprechen, dann kann im Prinzip jetzt jeder, der technisch ein bisschen Ahnung hat, meine Zuhausegeräte bedienen.
Oder das Türschloss öffnen.
Wenn du Pech hast, sogar jeder, der keine Ahnung hat, wenn irgendjemand ein nettes Tool baut und es ins Internet stellt, dann musst du es in Zweifel nur noch runterladen.
Wie kann sowas, also kann sowas verhindert werden?
Ja, man macht sowas nicht. Man packt keine default-Keys in Geräte. Das ist halt eine Convenience-Abwendung. Die haben sich überlegt, wie kann ich das dem Endanwender möglichst einfach machen, die ausgepackte Glühbirne ans Laufen zu bringen. Haben sich dann für diese Lösung entschieden. Und ja, war keine gute Idee. Das ist halt, wenn du genug Aufwand treibst, kannst du aus einem Gerät immer die Geheimnisse entlocken. Ist halt die Frage.
Aber wie könnte man das anders machen?
Du könntest auf diese Glühbirne eine zufällige, wirklich zufällige Idee draufdrucken, die du diesem Router mitteilen musst, oder diesem Zigbee Gateway. Und dann kann er mit dem Ding reden. Sollte man aber auch nicht so machen wie die aktuellen WLAN-Router-Hersteller, die dann so eine Zufallszahler draufdrucken, die von der Mac-Adresse oder der Seriennummer abgeleitet ist. Die kann man dann auch wieder erraten.
Genau, die nicht zufällig ist.
Okay, also im Karton der Lampe läge ein Zettel drin, darauf steht ein Code.
Die will man schon so mit Laser auf das Gehäuse drucken.
Aber in dem Karton drin, so dass man es nicht von außen lesen kann, ist ein Code, den ich erst sehe. Wenn ich die Lampe raushole, den gebe ich ein.
Aber zusammenfassend ist wirklich das Problem, das die Hersteller haben. Es muss einfach sein. Es muss im Produktionsprozess gut machbar sein. Deswegen hatte man diese Durchzählbarkeit von Schlüsseln beim WLAN-Router. Und trotzdem muss es sicher sein. Und in diesem Spannungsfeld leben halt die Hersteller. Es muss einfach und sicher sein.
Ich frage mal andersrum. Wie sähe denn dein Internet of Things Gerät aus, das ihr euch installieren würdet? Was für Anforderungen müsste das erfüllen?
Es müsste in jedem Fall ohne externe Server, die nicht unter der eigenen Kontrolle sind, auskommen. Das kann ja immer noch eine Option sein. Wie der Kollege beim Fitbit eben sagte, vielleicht klicke ich auf den Knopf und sage, werte meine Daten noch besser aus und dann schicke ich sie raus. Aber ich sollte erstmal die Option haben, die Daten unter meiner Kontrolle zu haben. Am liebsten auch die Gegenstelle, womit das Gerät redet. Optimalerweise auf dem Gerät eine Firmware, die möglicherweise sogar Open Source ist, sodass ich reingucken kann und sehen kann, ach, das schickt meine Daten nicht nur an den einen Server, sondern auch noch an den anderen oder ähnliche Dinge.
Oder erfasst andere Daten, von denen ich gar nicht weiß, dass es die erfasst und schickt die noch mit raus. Also ich möchte schon maximale Kontrolle haben und so eine Wahlfreiheit. Möchte ich das lokal mit meinem Raspberry Pi, Banana Pi, was auch immer, oder dem Open-WRT-Router, der da rumsteht, auswerten und damit steuern? Oder gehe ich in den Convenience-Way und sage, es gibt da draußen verschiedene Dienstleister, die bieten mir das an, ich schicke meine Daten dahin und die werden das für mich außen steuern lassen.
Und das Requirement, das ich dazu fügen möchte, und das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich das Schwierigste ist, obwohl es das kann, muss es halt immer noch für Leute, also im Prinzip für jedermann bedienbar sein. Weil eine Sache, die irgendwie wahnsinnig toll für uns drei, vier hier im Studio funktionieren würde, würde halt die erste Serie nicht überleben, weil wenn es keiner sonst auf dieser Welt kauft, und das wäre halt sehr, sehr schade.
Gibt es das schon, was ihr jetzt beschrieben habt als Produkt?
Naja, zumindest in der Smart Home Welt ist es halt so, dass sich da eine ganze Menge Leute hingesetzt haben und quasi diesen zentralen Punkt ersetzt haben. Also dann nimmst du halt nicht die Steuerzentrale, die dir dein Hersteller dazu packt, sondern zum Beispiel einen Raspberry Pi oder was auch immer mit einem USB-Stick dran, der so ein Funk-Dings drin hat, was da mit deinen Heizungs-Sachen redet. Du kannst also schon die Produkte nehmen, also den Heizungsregler und den ganzen Kram, den du vielleicht sogar gerade von Wattenfall bekommen hast. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was die verteilen, aber es gibt eine ganze Menge Lösungen. Und dann tauschst du einfach die Zentrale aus. Das heißt, die Endgeräte benutzt du, aber das Ding, was wirklich mit dem Internet redet, das nimmst du ihm weg und stellst ein eigenes dahin. Und dann greifst du halt selber drauf zu.
Aber das ist dann so eine Bastellösung, also dann ist quasi lauter die A.
Naja, also mittlerweile ist es schon, ich glaube nicht, letztendlich, du startest halt ein kleines Programm und steckst einen USB-Stick rein. Also das ist schon auf dem Niveau angekommen, wo das eigentlich, sag mal so, wenn du das nicht hinkriegst, solltest du überlegen, ob du vielleicht von dem Internet of Things erst noch Abstand hältst.
Dann so weit erst mal dazu. Was ich von euch gern auch wissen würde, wenn ihr Lust habt, ist, was ihr euch vom Internet of Things wünscht. Also welche Art und Weise der Haus online anbringen würdet ihr euch wünschen. Wollt ihr zum Beispiel so einen Kühlschrank, der Essen bestellt, oder wollt ihr eure Lampen steuern, oder habt ihr noch eine ganz andere Idee? 0331 70 97 110 Ansonsten haben wir jetzt noch eine kleine Musik von Tears of God, Cross My Heart, Hope to Die. Danach gibt es die Nachrichten über Down Verkehr.
Und jetzt zu einer Band...
deren Konzerte eigentlich gar keine Konzerte sind. Sondern eher so ne Art Freakshow.
Und ihr seid die Hauptdarsteller.
Mittwoch, 10. Februar.
Deichkind live in der Max-Schweling-Halle.
Die Polizei hat ihre Razzien gegen mutmaßliche Islamisten in Berlin am Abend beendet. Es seien keine gefährlichen Gegenstände gefunden worden, sagte Polizeipräsident Kant im RBB-Fernsehen. Man habe zuvor einen ernst zu nehmenden Hinweis erhalten, dass entsprechende Aktionen in Berlin geplant seien. In Britze wurden zwei Verdächtige festgenommen. Einen zweiten Einsatz gab es am Nachmittag in einer Moschee in Charlottenburg. Es soll Hinweise gegeben haben, dass dort ein Anschlag geplant wurde. Auch Deutschland wird sich am Militäreinsatz gegen die Terror-Militie IS in Syrien beteiligen. Das hat die Bundesregierung beschlossen, um Frankreich im Anti-Terror-Kampf zu unterstützen. Demnach werden mehrere Aufklärungsflugzeuge der Bundeswehr bereitgestellt. Sie sollen Infos über Angriffsziele in Syrien liefern. Außerdem werden Tankflugzeuge und ein Kriegsschiff der Marine zum Einsatz kommen. Der Bundestag muss noch zustimmen. In Deutschland sind jetzt schon deutlich mehr Flüchtlinge angekommen, als von der Bundesregierung erwartet. Sie hatte bis zum Jahresende mit 800.000 Menschen gerechnet. Die Bundesländer sagen aber, dass es schon fast eine Million Flüchtlinge sind. Demnach kamen allein im November so viele Menschen an wie noch nie in einem Monat. Die Bundespolizei zielte bis Anfang der Woche mehr als 190.000 Einreisen. In Oranienburg sind vier Weltkriegsbomben auf einmal entdeckt worden. Sie sollen morgen Vormittag entschärft werden. Die Stadt teilte mit, dass die Bomben auf einem Grundstück im Ortsteil Lenitz gefunden wurden. Bis 8.30 Uhr morgen früh müssen die Anwohner im Umkreis von einem Kilometer ihre Häuser verlassen. Etwa 4.300 Menschen sind betroffen. In dem Sperrkreis liegt auch der S-Bahnhof Lenitz. Die Bahn will einen Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen einrichten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, die liegen in Berlin-Tempelhof bei 2°C, in Küpenich sind es 4°C. Falkensee meldet minus 1°C, Prenzlau 1°C und Rangsdorf und Königsbusterhausen jeweils 3°C. Nachts sinken die Temperaturen um die 0°C, kriegen wir in Berlin und Brandenburg. Dazu kann es neblig sein. Morgen lockert es im Tagesverlauf auf und es soll überwiegend sonnig werden, bei maximal 4 bis 6°C. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 stattdringt Richtung Neukölln. Die Überleitung zum Abzweig Steglitz ist wegen einer Baustelle bis morgen früh gesperrt. Aus Brandenburg haben wir keine Meldungen, aber dafür zwei von der Berliner S-Bahn. Und zwar auf der Linie S5 fahren zwischen Strausberg und Strausberg Nord bis Sonntag Busse Stadtbahn. Ebenso wie bei der S-Bahn Linie S25 zwischen Schönholz und Tegel. Da aber nur bis heute Betriebsschluss. Da wo es geht, reich eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, die letzte halbe Stunde steht an und wir reden heute hier im Internet über das Internet of Things mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club und das sind Mutag, Salon, guten Abend. Und der Peter. Hallo. Und wir haben in den ersten 90 Minuten, Gott, die Sendung ist eigentlich schon vorbei in meinem Kopf. In den ersten 90 Minuten gelernt, was Internet of Things ist und dass es halt noch nicht so weit ist, wie man sich das wünscht. Und das Hauptproblem, dass es damit gibt, ist, da werden Dinge in unserer Wohnung zum Beispiel installiert, die bequem über eine App zu bedienen sind, aber die sozusagen auch Daten an den Anbieter übertragen, was eigentlich gar nicht notwendig ist. Und die Sicherheitsbedingungen, wie die funktionieren, das ist alles noch so eine Sache.
Naja.
So. Zwei Themen wollen wir auf jeden Fall noch besprechen. Das eine ist politisch und das andere hat was mit Geld zu tun. Welches nehmen wir zuerst?
Geld?
Na, es geht noch um Versicherung.
Lassen wir damit anfangen.
Gut, fangen wir damit an. Versicherung. Was wollen die Versicherungen vom Internet of Things?
Ja, da gab es jetzt die ersten Versicherungen, die auf die schöne Idee gekommen sind. Wenn sie dir eine kleine Boxness-Auto einbauen, die deinen Fahrverhalten analysiert und du ordentlich fährst, wird deine Versicherung günstiger. Das Konzept kann man natürlich dann auch direkt sehr schön auf diese ganzen wie unser Fitbit übertragen, wenn ich eine Krankenversicherung abschließe. Habe ich jetzt so noch nicht gesehen, aber ist natürlich naheliegend.
Es gibt da auch schon so ein bisschen was am Horizont. Es gab jetzt schon Anfragen von Apple und Ähnlichem, ob sie nicht auf anonymisierte Daten, der Gesundheitsdatenkarten zugreifen und so. Total anonym.
Was will Apple? Will worauf zugreifen?
Na ja, wir haben ja jetzt auch demnächst ganz viele statistische Daten, die aus der Gesundheitskarte rausfallen, weil es ja alles direkt digital ist. Und es gibt jetzt wohl schon erste Anfragen von Anbietern, die so in diesem ganzen eHealth-Kram dabei unterwegs sind, ob man dann diese Daten nicht da vielleicht statistisch mal so auswerten könnte und so vielleicht so kopieren und so. Aber total anonym.
Was wollen die dann damit?
Na ja, ich denke mal, die Versicherung wollen halt ihre Statistiken ein bisschen updaten über Lebenserwartungen und ähnliches.
Ach so, ich habe gerade verstanden, die Apple will von den Krankenkassen. Nein, die Versicherungen wollen...
Na ja, es sind diverse Anbieter, die das wohl wollen. Unter anderem halt auch Apple, weil sie mit ihrem Fitbit natürlich einerseits Live-Daten haben von den Anwendern. Und wenn man das schön korreliert mit Gesundheitsdaten, kann man da vielleicht auch mehr rauskriegen. Keine Ahnung, also da ist einiges in Bewegung gerade.
Na ja, also bei den Versicherungen fand ich jetzt zumindest den interessanten Punkt, dass dein Verhalten dazu führt, dass du zum Beispiel mehr oder weniger Versicherungen zahlst. Das heißt, das funktioniert auch andersrum. Du wirst halt konditioniert. Das heißt auch andersrum, vielleicht sagt die Krankenkasse so, wir gucken mal.
Dein Schritt steht bei 5.000.
Du läufst nicht genug. Außerdem haben wir an deiner Armbewegung erkannt, du hebst öfter mal ein Bierglas mehr als du solltest. Wir stufen dich erst mal hoch oder wir versichern dich gar nicht erst. Oder vielleicht sagt auch, also diese Daten sind dann ja erst mal da. Vielleicht ist auch dein Arbeitgeber. Also ich habe jetzt mal bei Fitbit nachgeguckt. Also dich einzustellen ist mir eigentlich ein zu großes Risiko. Geh mal mehr joggen und komm dann wieder. Also die Daten sind halt erst mal da.
Und das das Schlimme ist, wenn du dich halt dafür entscheidest, da nicht mitmachen zu wollen, wird deine Versicherung halt teurer. Du kriegst die günstige Tarife nicht mehr.
Und das ist ja eigentlich egal, ob es teurer wird oder genauso teuer wie heute. Das Problem ist halt, was als das niveau als das akzeptable Niveau eingestuft wird. Und je mehr Leute da mitmachen, umso mehr wird halt gesagt, das akzeptable Niveau einer Versicherung liegt halt da, wo die meisten Leute abschließen. Und wenn viele Leute dann diesen Monitoring-Tarif, sag ich mal, wählen, dann ist das halt so eine Gruppendynamik.
Das heißt, man kann über kurzer Langzeit dazu gezwungen werden.
Zwingen klingt immer so, als ob da jemand mit einem Gewehr hinter steht. Das ist aber gar nicht mehr notwendigerweise. Das ist einfach ein gesellschaftlicher Effekt, der da eintritt.
Du hast schon die Wahl. Du musst noch ein bisschen weiter einen Weg zurücklegen. Also es ist halt aufwendiger, du musst mehr Geld dafür bezahlen. Oder länger suchen nach einer Versicherung, die das noch anmietet.
Das Spannende ist sozusagen, dass dann die Leute, die das Angebot annehmen, sich darüber im Klaren sein müssten, dass sie Verantwortung damit tragen, dass der gesellschaftliche Druck aufgebaut wird oder nicht.
Ja, aber tust du das? Ich glaube, die meisten Leute sagen, ich wollte eigentlich immer schon mal gesund leben.
Die Gegenfrage machen die Leute sich Gedanken, wenn sie ihre Kontaktdaten oder ihre Adressbücher bei Facebook hochladen, so komplett, mit allen Kontakten.
Naja, es ist nicht die Frage, ob sie es machen, sondern ob sie es sollten.
Naja, sollten sie nicht, weil die Leute sollen schon eigentlich selber entscheiden können, ob Facebook sie kennt oder nicht.
Vielleicht, um das mal wieder in den Alltag zurückzuholen. Es gibt ja, hat ja wahrscheinlich jeder dieses Kärtchen, von einem Zahnarzt einmal im Jahr reinschreibt, dass du beim Zahnarzt warst und dann ist dein Zahnersatz irgendwann belegert. Das ist bis jetzt so ein Papierstück, so ein Bonusheft. Und es gibt jetzt auch die ersten Zahnbürsten mit Bluetooth und Internet-Anbindung. Also warum sollte nicht irgendjemand auf die Idee kommen, genau wie dieses Heftchen jetzt, natürlich zwingt dich niemand dieses Heftchen zu benutzen. Und das ist ja auch ziemlich datenspar so. Da steht ja nur drin, dass du einmal im Jahr beim Zahnarzt warst. Aber warum sollte man das nicht einfach weiterführen und sagen, naja, wenn du dir nicht dreimal am Tag die Zähne putzt, dann wird dein Zahnarzt auch teurer. Und das ist dann vielleicht erstmal freiwillig. Und irgendwann ist das wie dieses Heftchen einfach der Default-Weg. Weil es hat ja jeder eine Bluetooth-Zahnbürste, warum auch nicht. Und dann wird es auf einmal so ein Problem eventuell. Weil dann bist du ja schon gezwungen, dich dieser ganzen Sache zu unterwerfen. Und bist auch gezwungen, so ein Gerät zu haben. Bist gezwungen, immer diese Hintenanbindung zu haben. Bist gezwungen, ja, also dein Verhalten wird fremdbestimmt durch Konditionierung. Weil du kriegst halt ein Zöckerchen, nämlich die billigeren Zähne oder was auch immer, wenn du mitspielst.
Und das Schlimme ist, wir werden die ersten, also die ersten Effekte werden wir sehen über diese Autoversicherungsnummer. Die wird nämlich zuerst kommen. Und da Deutsche und die Auto sehr verliebt ineinander sind und man da sicherlich gerne den ein oder anderen Cent spart, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das sogar sehr gut funktioniert.
Aber da kommen wir jetzt auch zur Politik, wo ich sowieso gleich wieder hin wollte. Weil Deutschland hat ja zur Zeit zumindest immer der Ruf zu sagen, sehr, sehr schwierig und streng zu sein, was den Datenschutz angeht. Und glaubt ihr wirklich, dass zugelassen wird, dass so eine Dinge installiert werden im Auto? Also weil ich habe schon häufiger mit Rechtsanwälten gesprochen und Datenschutz ist ja in Deutschland ein Grundrecht. Man kann Grundrechte nicht einfach so abtreten.
Na das Problem ist, das ist ja total freiwillig diese Box.
Also wenn ich hier mal gucke. Aber so geht es nicht. Sondern es gibt bestimmte Arten, die man, also man darf das nicht machen sozusagen. Selbst wenn man will. Also der Anbieter dürfte es quasi nicht anbieten.
Solange dieser Anbieter sich ans deutsche Datenschutzrecht hält bei der Speicherung deiner Daten, darf der das ruhig anbieten. Das heißt ja nicht, dass du ein Recht darauf hast, du kannst ja einfach nicht Auto fahren oder kein Auto besitzen. Aber der Datenschutz hilft in dem Fall, ja eigentlich nur deswegen, dass der Anbieter sie sicher speichern muss nach den Anforderungen, die das BSI da glaube ich gestellt hat. Das heißt aber nicht, dass er dir das nicht anbieten darf. Das heißt nur, dass er auf deine Daten aufpassen muss.
Google Now trackt ja auch komplett wo du bist und zeichnet das auf und macht da Bewegungsprofile. Sagt dir auch keiner was gegen? Also passiert ja. Hab ich bisher auch noch niemanden gehört, der sich da aufregt.
Spannend wird es dann nochmal, wenn Versicherungen dazu kommen. Da kenne ich mich rechtlich tatsächlich nicht so aus, ob es da noch mal spezielle Regulierungen gibt in Gesetzen, die jetzt das Versicherungswesen betreffen.
Ich vermute mal, so lange es einen Opt-out gibt, aber der halt mehr kostet, wird das wahrscheinlich irgendwie rechtend sein.
Wie ist es denn jetzt mit der Politik eigentlich und der ganzen Daten, die da anfällt, gibt es da? Wir haben da am Anfang bei IT-Gipfel gesagt, dass angeblich gesagt wurde, vielleicht müssen wir mal ein bisschen weniger Datenschutz und so. Wie war das genau?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass da, vermute ich, irgendwo ein Missverständnis da ist. Es gibt da eine ganze Menge Buzzwords. Eins ist zum Beispiel, dass wir jetzt ganz viel Big Data machen müssen. Und Big Data, das klingt ja so, als ob wir da unheimlich viele Daten verarbeiten müssen. Es ist alles groß und Big Data funktioniert nur, wenn wir ganz, ganz viele Daten haben. Und dann gibt es diesen Begriff der Datensparsamkeit. Das klingt so, als ob wir da ganz, ganz wenige Daten haben. Und für die Politik geht das nicht zusammen. Das führt dann dazu, dass bei dem IT-Gipfel der Herr Dobrindt auf der Bühne stand und meinte, diese Datensparsamkeit müssen wir mal ganz dringend überdenken. Die passt nicht mehr zu der Zeit. Das ist, also wir brauchen Innovation und Fortschritt. Dazu brauchen wir Big Data. Und zu Big Data, das geht nicht mit dieser Datensparsamkeit. Wir brauchen ja Daten. Und Frau Merkel trieb das dann noch auf die Formulierung, dass Daten, dass ich glaube, dass das Öl oder das Gold des nächsten Jahrtausends sind oder irgendwie sowas. Weil die alle nicht verstanden haben, dass Datensparsamkeit und irgendwie Innovation und Fortschritt und Big Data sich nicht unbedingt ausschließen. Es geht vor allem darum, was für Daten ich da erfasse und verarbeite. Und Beispiel Carsharing. Carsharing kann ich nur machen, wenn ich die Standortdaten der Autos habe und die mit meinem Handy in Verbindung bringen kann. Aber ich brauche zum Beispiel, wenn ich eine Google-Anfrage mache, für eine Standard-Anfrage nicht unbedingt den Aufenthaltsort, dessen, den der anfragt, wenn er nicht gerade nach Restaurants in der Nähe fragt. Und es gibt eine ganze Menge von Diensten, die mit weniger Datenspeicherung funktionieren würden und damit datensparsam wären. Es aber aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen nicht sind. Und da heißt es glaube ich durchaus, Naja, Missverständnis in der Politik da. Also von diesem Begriff Datenspeisamkeit.
Aber heißt das, dass wir uns jetzt davon verabschieden langsam? Weil Missverständnis ist ja nur der Herr, wenn die Politik das fordert.
Ich glaube nicht. In einem anderen Punkt habe ich zumindest am RT-Gefühl gemerkt, dass lustigerweise in der Wirtschaft einen Standortvorteil gesehen wird, wenn wir weiterhin beim Datenschutz und bei der Sicherheit vorne sind. Es gab dieses Panel, wie gesagt, mit unter anderem Herrn Demisier und Frank Rieger vom CCC, wo Frank gesagt hat, naja, vielleicht sollten wir in Deutschland einfach mal bei diesem ganzen Industrie 4.0, was nichts anderes ist als Internet of Things, auf die Industrie übertragen, wenn irgendwelche Roboterarme da miteinander reden. Vielleicht sollten wir da bei dieser ganzen Entwicklung so ein ganz, ganz kleines bisschen langsam auch vorwärts gehen, dafür aber vielleicht die Sicherheit von Anfang an einbauen und nicht versuchen, hinterher reinzufriemeln, weil das funktioniert eh nicht. Und da gab es von ihren Wirtschaftsvertretern im Saal Applaus. Made in Germany als Qualitätsmerkmal mit der Aussage, dieser Roboterarme kommt aus Deutschland, der durchschlägt nicht die Fabrikhalle und bringt Arbeiter um, weil da ist die Sicherheit von Anfang an drin eingebaut.
Naja, aber so irgendwie Roboter-Sicherheit und Datensparsamkeit sind noch mal…
Das ist ja ähnlich. Wenn man Datenschutz als Marke und Standort Vorteil etabliert hat, zu sagen, wir sind hier in einer Umgebung, wo wir auch so was Wert legen, zieht das durchaus so. Nicht umsonst haben Firmen wie Google und Ähnliches in Berlin das Headquarter, wo sie sich um Datenschutz kümmern, weil hier halt die strengsten Regulierungen dafür sind.
Naja, aber es ist schon die Frage, das haben die ja nur hier, weil sie das halt machen müssen, weil sie sonst irgendwie Ärger kriegen, und das momentan auch so ist. Und dieses Made in Germany war früher so ein Ingenieurskunststil, also die Sachen sind besonders robust, sie sind technisch besonders gut. Und das sind ja auch im Ausland, ist ja eine Qualität gewesen, die man halt gerne wollte. Während halt niemand irgendwo, also zumindest so gefühlt, jetzt danach nach Datenschutzprodukten fragt, also gibt es denn überhaupt einen Markt für, ist das nicht so Wunschdenken? Also einerseits von Menschen, die halt gerne datensparsam sein wollen, die denken, ja genau, guck mal Industrie, damit kannst du auch Geld verdienen. Andererseits von Industrie, die sozusagen immer dem innovativen US-Markt hinterherhängt und dann so hofft, okay, jetzt könnte man hier vielleicht damit noch, vielleicht wäre das ein Siegel. Aber ist es denn realistisch, dass man irgendwie so Made in Germany, Made with German Datenschutz als internationale Siegel etabliert? Ich halte das für ein bisschen naiv.
Naja, das spielt aber auch gleichzeitig noch in andere Sachen rein. Wenn du nicht die eine oder den einen Anbieter hast oder die eine Plattform, auf die deine Daten hochgeladen werden und du deine Daten lokaler speicherst, also jetzt mal mit dieser Home Automation als Beispiel, lässt dich natürlich auch auf industrielle Maßstäbe übertragen. Also wenn du quasi denjenigen, der diese Technik betreibt, in Kontrolle seiner Daten lässt, dann hast du auch viel eher die Möglichkeit, Interoperabilität herzustellen. Aber wollen die Leute das denn? Ja, da komme ich jetzt gerade drauf. Was wir gerade hatten bei Wattenfall, also was der Anrufer sagte ist, er ist jetzt im Prinzip darauf angewiesen, dass es Wattenfall ist. Das ist natürlich nicht unbedingt im Interesse des Stromanbieters, der ihm das jetzt zur Verfügung stellt, aber es ist im Interesse der Gerätehersteller, dass Leute einfach in der Lage sind quasi auch mal ihr Gerät zu kaufen und nicht immer bei der Stammmarke zu bleiben. Und es ist im Interesse von Konsumenten, weil sie sich nicht in so ein Wendolok in reinfahren. Also das schönste Beispiel, was wir da gerade aktuell in der Politik verfolgen, ist der Routerzwang, der jetzt aufgelöst wurde. Ich muss also jetzt nicht mehr den ranzigen Plastorouter, den mir mein Provider hinstellt, so akzeptieren, sondern ich darf jetzt auch wieder den Router meiner Wahl dort betreiben. Und wenn wir jetzt nicht zu weit abschweifen wollten, könnte ich Geschichten erzählen, die mehr als ein Ort der Mauer und das sowas halt sehr wichtig ist.
Aber das ist ja was anderes. Ein Anbieter stellt eine Internetdienstleistung zur Verfügung, dass sie an der Infrastruktur teilnehmen kann und sagt dann muss das Gerät dazukaufen. Bei Internet of Things ist es ja so, das Gerät ist die Dienstleistung.
Naja, das Heizungsthermostat und das Gateway für zu Hause ist halt so ein Gesamtprodukt und dann bist du auf den angewiesen. Aber das lustige ist, von wegen eigene Kontrolle und offene Systeme, wenn du die anguckst bei Twitter und Facebook, kannst du dir ein ZIP-Archiv runterladen mit allen deinen persönlichen Daten, weil sie in den USA dazu verpflichtet sind, dir als Konsument das anzubieten. Also da ist schon so eine gesetzliche Vorschrift, dass ich meine Daten da auch wieder wiederkriegen muss, komplett und unverändert, um sie woanders eventuell wieder einspeisen zu können.
Aber? Wiederkriegen von Daten ist halt schwierig. Du kriegst eine Kopie davon. Du kannst nicht sagen, gib sie mir, ich gehe damit zu jemand anderem und du hast sie jetzt nicht mehr. Das ist halt der entscheidende Unterschied.
Ja, da glaube ich nach wie vor, es gibt nicht wirklich eine Motivation oder sozusagen breites Interesse daran, dass Leute das wollen.
Ich denke auch, was da gesagt wurde, Standortvorteil, das kann man wahrscheinlich auch genauso gut andersrum fantasieren. Also es könnte sich da genauso gut jemand hinstellen, sagen so, wenn wir jetzt den Datenschutz komplett aufheben, dann können wir hier viel mehr Geld verdienen, weil unsere Wirtschaft würde hier aufblühen, weil wir viel mehr mit den Daten machen können.
Also das ist das, was halt diskutiert wird und das, was Dobrindt und Merkel von sich gegeben haben. Dass wir genau das tun müssen, damit wir weiterhin Marktführer werden.
Genau, deswegen ich bin nicht so optimistisch wie du, dass wir da jetzt argumentativ gewonnen haben und Deutschland jetzt Datenschutzland wird.
Das garantiert mich, aber es ist eine Chance. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit die beim Datenschutz gesehen und genommen wird von der Industrie, weil da gab es entgegengesetzte Äußerungen. Bei dem Security Aspekt, da scheint es zu funktionieren, was auch schon mal ganz schön ist, aber beim Datenschutz wäre es eigentlich auch ganz nett.
Also womit ich gerade daran denken muss, was ist eine Urbane mit so einem Thema, wo es Innovationen mal gab, die dann einfach so sagen, dass es versandelt. Und zwar hab ich neulich, wir sind ja relativ viel bei Google, fällt mir auf, aber es ist halt auch ein gutes Beispiel, Street View. Also dieses, ich guck mir an, wo ich bin. Das ist in Deutschland einmal gemacht worden und dann nie wieder aktualisiert worden, weil Google gesagt hat, das ist uns einfach zu aufwendig. Ich hab das halt neulich geguckt, also das Haus, wo ich wohne, das ist immer noch genauso verpixelt, wie es vor 5 oder 6 Jahren war.
Wird es auch bleiben.
Wird es auch bleiben, so dass es passiert. Also Google, also der US-Anbieter, der sich nicht um das anscheinend kümmert, sagt, das ist uns zu aufwendig, wir lassen das. Da ist aber niemand in die Bresche gesprungen, hat gesagt, dann machen wir so ein geiles Street View-Angebot. Das gibt es halt irgendwie nicht.
Na ja, weil jeder andere auch in dieselbe Problematik reinläuft. Also das ist ja keine Lex-Google-Level, sondern das betrifft jeden, der diese Daten nochmal erheben würde. Und du kannst nur hoffen an der Stelle, dass der Presse-Rummel über dein Street View nicht so groß ist, auf das weniger Leute Einspruch erheben.
Genau, dann könnte man sagen, das wird doch beim Internet of Things genauso sein. Es wird halt irgendwie international eine Entwicklung geben. Und in Deutschland werden wir halt weiterhin unsere Blühlampen mit der Hand anschalten.
Ja, wie gesagt, bis heute, also ich kann nur von mir ausgehen. Ich würde mir das halt nicht hinstellen. Aber ich sehe schon, wir sind da natürlich immer die Ausnahme.
Also ich würde es mir nicht hinstellen, wenn ich auf zentrale Serveranbiesungen bin. Aber ich denke auch, dass da gewisse Hersteller durchaus verstehen, dass du alleine wegen der Latenz und wegen der Infrastruktur, die sie selber vorhalten müssen, wenn sie mal viele Nutzer da drauf haben, das gar nicht wollen. Also wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass dieses Internet of Things richtig abhebt und ich habe dann da irgendwie 60, 80, 100.000 Benutzer, die alle ihre Glüben steuern und jedes Mal das über meine Server machen, skaliert das irgendwann so überhaupt nicht mehr. Und dann wird sowas kommen, wie das Apple TV oder das Google Ding, so ein kleiner Kasten, der zu Hause steht, der genau diese Dinge übernimmt.
Ich denke, diese Cloud-Anbindung oder Server-Anbindung ist ja auch nicht nur, weil die Leute Daten sammeln wollen. Wenn du jetzt, du möchtest ja dieses Feature haben, ich bin auch unterwegs und kann von unterwegs zu Hause etwas steuern. Und das ist heutzutage einfach nicht trivial möglich, wenn du nicht den externen Server benutzt. Weil die Leute haben halt diesen irgendeinen Router zu Hause, der hat für gewöhnlich irgendwie eine dynamische IP-Adresse. Und wenn du überhaupt noch eine Public-IP-Adresse kriegst, V6 ist noch nicht ausgerollt. Deine Glühlampe hat auf jeden Fall keine Public-Adresse zu Hause. Du müsstest von dem Kunden sehr viel technisches Know-how verlangen, damit es nicht über den externen Server geht, damit es direkt funktioniert. Also die Bastel-Lösung, von dem wir vorhin sprachen, kann natürlich auch eine große Firma bauen, aber es sind einfach technische Hürden, die heutzutage immer noch da sind. Wenn wir irgendwann mal den großen IPv6-Rollout haben und alles ein bisschen weiter ist, könnte ich mir auch gut vorstellen, dass ein paar der Anbieter genau das, was Mutags gerade sagt, überlegen, dass es jetzt so einfach für den Kunden ist. Ich kann dir ein Kistchen zu Hause hinstellen, ich muss gar nicht mehr für den Server betreiben, zahlt der Kunde den Strom, ist ja voll super. Man muss ja nicht mal das Schlimmste annehmen. Es gibt einfach auch handfeste Gründe, warum man diese Anbindung macht und die Daten woanders lagert. Genauso wie das Ding steht bei dir zu Hause, du kippst die Cola drüber, die Daten sind weg, der Kunde ist am heulen. Wenn es im Rechenzentrum ist, passiert es vielleicht nicht so schnell mit der Cola.
Auf der anderen Seite, die Gegensache, die sich dazu aufmachen lässt, ist, in dem Moment, wo jemand Geld ausgeben muss, um deine Daten zu hosten, und das sind ja laufende Kosten, die ich mir nicht über einmaliges Bezahlen dieses Gegenstandes, der da jetzt diese Daten sendet, refinanzieren kann. Das ist natürlich die Frage, wie finanziert er das Ganze, finanziert er das wirklich noch im Laufe des Verkaufs neuer Geräte, oder gibt er vielleicht auch noch Daten weg, um das zu refinanzieren? Wäre jetzt die Gegenthese dazu.
Puh, es bleibt also noch spannend, was Internet of Things angeht, und obwohl ich es nicht so offen lassen mag, glaube ich, kommen wir heute nicht zu einem besseren Schluss als diesem. Es ist noch viel zu tun. Was glaubt ihr, wann reden wir, wie viele Jahre werden vergehen, bevor es das Chaos-Radio gibt, weil es wirklich jeder hat? Tipp?
Fünf.
Ja, das halte ich schon sehr ehrlich.
Und, allerletzte Frage, werden wir jemals den Kühlschrank kriegen, der Essen bestellt oder wird das für immer ein Wunschtraum bleiben?
Ich denke, wir werden die Küche kriegen, die Essen bestellt.
Die ganze Küche gleich. Kocht die dann auch?
Nee, also es gibt mittlerweile schon so einen Prototypen von so einer Küchenzeile, die mit Roboter-Armen kocht. Aber ganz ehrlich, ein bisschen kochen will ich selber, ansonsten kann ich mir auch gleich die Pizza selber im Internet klicken.
Also ich finde Roboterkoch ganz sympathisch, will ich haben. Sehr schön. So, Chaosradio 218, das ist Instead of Things. Wir haben es angerissen und aufgemacht und müssen es jetzt so stehen lassen. Mal gucken, was dann auch passiert. Habt ihr noch Ankündigungen zu letztes Chaosradio im Monat? Da stehen ja manchmal Dinge an.
Sogar das letzte im Jahr.
Im Jahr, aber bestimmt im Monat sowieso im Jahr.
Ja, und statt des Chaosradios oder der Grund, warum es kein Chaosradio im Dezember gibt, ist der 23. Chaos Communication Congress.
Vielleicht auch der 32.
23. Der 32. natürlich. Und für den gibt es tatsächlich jetzt auch Tickets. Da haben viele Leute lange drauf gewartet. Und jetzt unter tickets.events.ccc.de zuhaben. Tickets für jenen Kongress im Hamburg, im Konferenzzentrum.
Vom 27.
Kauf, kauf, kauf. Warum sollen wir dahin kommen?
Weil es total klasse ist und weil neue Leute dort herzlich empfangen werden, unter anderem von den Chaos-Parten, die jeden erstmal, der es gerne wünscht, an die Hand nimmt und ihm zeigt, was es wundervolles gibt und wo er am besten seine Interessen ausleben kann.
Also falls ihr euch fragt, was ist denn eigentlich dieser komische CCC, dann könnt ihr euch das auf diesem Kongress sehr gut angucken, also wirklich die beste Antwort, die ich diese Frage geben kann. Und es gibt dort wie gesagt ein Projekt für Leute, die zum ersten Mal da sind, das sind die Chaos-Parten, wo Leute, die schon mal auf dem Kongress waren, mit euch zusammen über den Kongress ziehen und sagen, so hier guckt ihr diesen Vortrag an, bastelt an diesem Ding mit, macht dieses Schloss auf, dort ist das Bällebad. Solche Dinge, also falls wir uns dort sehen wollen, könnt ihr gerne auch dorthin kommen. Das war das Chaos-Radio 218, hier kommt jetzt Flo Heiler, bewirft euch mit Punk-Musik, ich verabschiede mich von Mutax. Dann Nemo.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Und der Peter. Schüsseln. Die Sendung erscheint als Podcast in dieser Nacht auf fritz.de, sehr bald dann auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich spreche Mikrofone und habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.